- But if this little
commercial break
from the episode does anything,
please understand
the only person
you need permission
from is yourself.
("Monday To Monday" by Saba)
Saba, I've been telling you.
("Free As A Bird" by Rom)
- [Gary] Tuesday morning,
back on the grind
after a nice weekend.
I haven't taken a Monday,
President's Day in my entire
career so that was fun.
But as the kids get older
want to sneak in more time.
Hacking, always adjust.
You know, that is, that has
been the absolute pillar of my
success which is if I decide
tomorrow that I'm anti-hustle
and it's all about laying on the
beach and Zen-ing out mentally,
I'll own it.
I'm not scared.
Not scared to change my tune.
Obviously, there's a big
difference between change and
breaking your word.
Talked about that
in yesterday's episode.
But excited.
The weather
looks good this week.
- [Other Tyler] Yeah.
- It's pretty cool.
Should be a nice grinding week.
Today's a hectic day.
On my way to
go see David Levy,
president of
Turner Broadcasting.
Incredible guy, one of
my favorite executives.
Really one of the
more entrepreneurial senior
executives that
I've come across.
Just willing to do
stuff and that's why
he's had a great career.
Salesman at heart,
that always speaks to me.
I think we need to expand on
more DailyVee is salesmanship.
One of the biggest reasons I'm
pushing the 2017 Flip Challenge
is I genuinely believe that
whether you're 60 or 16 or 90 or
19 that learning how to sell is
one of the incredible advantages
in running a
business in your whole life.
So much of my career has been
being so good at sales that
I was able to wait for
the market to come to me and
a lot of strategies and things
I believe in are futuristic,
are 3 to 5 years away.
What do you do before everybody
wants to spend on Facebook?
wants to spend on social media?
What do you do before
everybody wants to drink
Spanish and Australian wines?
What do you do?
What you do is you find
the few people that are
actually out
there willing to buy.
One of the things
I talk a lot about is
not selling to
the unsellable. Right?
You know if
somebody's not willing to buy,
you've got no shot and so
just some of the patterns.
I find myself always
attracted to salespeople.
Avi, nobody's around.
Everybody's still off today?
- [Avi] Yeah, school's out.
- [Gary] Got it.
But the city seems quiet.
- [Avi] A lot less traffic.
("Free As A Bird" by Rom)
- [Gary] And then just
to have us all aligned,
me you and the one or two
people or three or whatever in
the trenches and then we can go
and then we can have kind of a
weekly kind of 10 minute
call, meeting in the office.
10, 15 minute just to
keep me somewhat abreast to it.
That's the real problem when
people kind of figure it out.
Yeah, he's got it.
Best city in the world.
'Sup man?
How are you?
- Good. My name's Mohammed.
- [Gary] Mohammed,
nice to meet you.
- I stopped by just
to show you some samples.
- Thank you, my friend.
- And check it out.
- I will.
- Let me know how
you feel about it.
- I will.
- Thank you, Gary.
- Let me get a card.
- Picture? A card?
- Yeah.
And the only
question that I have is like
how did you make the transition?
I know you were selling wine.
- [Gary] Yes.
- And how did you
make that transition from
selling physical product to--
- [Gary] Being a personal?
- Yeah.
- [Gary] It just takes time.
You know everybody sees me now.
- Yeah.
- [Gary] But in 2000,
1999, '98, you know.
How old are you?
- 25.
- [Gary] (laughs) Just
keep doing it for five years.
You'll be a young
man and it'll be there.
Patience.
- Thank you.
- [Gary] I mean it
when I say patience.
- 100% I believe that.
- Nice to meet ya. Picture?
Yeah, let's do it.
Always trying.
Alright, my man.
Real pleasure.
Take care.
- Sorry for the wrist.
- No, it's alright.
Hey.
Morning, what's up, bro?
Split ends?
- [Woman] Always.
(Gary laughs)
- [Gary] 'Sup Kenny?
- [Steve] Yo!
- [Gary] You gonna be my first
customer for my beanie company?
I'm definitely doing it.
I'm gonna launch a beanie brand.
100%.
- [Steve] Alright.
- [Gary] 100%.
- [Steve] I'm a fan of--
- Just feel like I love
wearing them so much.
I want to have summer
ones, too, that are thinner.
- [Steve] A lot of the
strategists I'm like you're now
just over-strategize,
I don't even.
You are over everyone's head.
You're over all
of culture's head.
It's like,
it's just kind of there.
You know?
- [Gary] Yeah.
- So, I need someone who is--
- A culture hacker?
- Yeah, that's a great way
to put it. Man, than person just
gets culture, understands--
- That's what I'm doing.
Like, right, Ty?
That's what I'm winning on.
I'm hanging out
with rappers who are
two years away
from being famous.
- Yeah.
- And when I see blood in the
water like Instagram I go all-in
and then everybody's
like how'd you get so much
more famous in three months?
It's 'cause I had that moment.
Like I truck along,
I truck along,
truck along and
then I have a moment.
It's kind of how I think about
the influencer Facebook thing.
- Yes.
- [Gary] Get me
three names ASAP.
Hey guys.
Hey.
- [Woman 2] What up?
- [Gary] Hello. Hey.
- [Woman 3] Hi.
(inaudible)
- [Gary] In real life form.
- [Woman 2] I feel
like I'm dreaming right now.
- [Woman 3] Do you believe the
term fake it 'til you make it?
- [Gary] I think
it's an interesting term.
It's funny that
you brought that up.
It's starting to hit my radar.
It's been asked
about a lot more lately.
I think it's a good one.
I think that I hate
fake it 'til you make it
in the way that it's
happening now which is
people are just
talking shit on social
and truly faking it.
Like there's dudes that
legitimately rent everything
from watches, cars, vacation
house and girls to paint a
picture to the outside
world on their social.
I hate that.
Like you're strategizing your
next step so while they think
you're listening to Kanye
you are taking the next move.
I think faking it 'til you
making it inside of your own
head, which is,
you're constantly
pushing yourself and
you believe in
yourself and you're realistic
about where you are.
That's why I brought
up document over,
you know, creating.
- Yep.
- If you guys are like hey,
we're two young entrepreneurs,
we're hustling.
We're just starting the
journey of this podcast,
of this vlog, of this thing,
it's way cooler than you guys
saying we're doing it.
That's what everybody's doing.
The second they put CEO or
entrepreneur in their Instagram,
they start trying to act it and
they think taking a selfie with
one of the Sharks on
Shark Tank proves it.
I think it's important
for people to know that
even in my level.
- Mhmmm.
- To spend a second
and just say thank you and
I just really appreciate it.
You're crushing.
- Thank you.
Yeah, so I've been here for six
months and before Lauren left
she was my mentor so
she taught me so much.
- [Gary] I just think
it's your work ethic as well.
- [Woman 4] Thank you.
- That's just
really impressive to me.
It's such a big thing for me.
Anyway, I just really genuinely
wanted to steal a minute of your
time and let you
know it's on my radar.
It's on the organization's radar
and if there's anything I can
ever do for you or
answer for you, I'm here.
- [Woman 2] I know you've
been talking about patience.
- [Gary] Yes.
- [Woman 2] Do you think
this is a Millennial issue?
- [Gary] Yes.
- [Woman 2] Sometimes we
work for one or two years--
- [Gary] Yes, yes, yes.
- [Woman 2] it's not really
progressing we just give up.
- [Gary] Yes. Sure, yep.
But good news, It's only
a Millennial thing 'cause
Millennials are the
young generation now.
It was a Gen X thing,
it was a Baby Boomer thing.
When you're young,
you're impatient.
Patience is always my model.
Like if you guys actually, all
four of you fuckers understood
how young you guys were and
how much time you actually had,
the new thing that I've said
this once or twice is if I could
let all four of you
feel how I feel right now,
like how young I feel.
How much more time I have.
Where I'm going.
The youth I feel in my soul,
you guys would
change everything you do.
If you guys knew, it would
change everything 'cause then
you'd get
really fucking patient,
you'd be really calculated.
You'd really build
real good building blocks
for something serious.
- [Man] How are you?
- [Gary] Really good, man.
It's a real pleasure.
How's it going so far?
- [Man] Yeah, it's good.
- Good.
- [Man] Yeah, it's busy.
- How long you been here now?
- [Man] August I started.
- Good.
- [Man] Yeah.
- You enjoying it?
- [Man] Yeah, it is,
it's really interesting.
- [Gary] That's a
whole different thing.
- [Man] I thought that was
really cool and interesting.
So yeah, huh.
- Yeah, and you should use
this meeting as permission
to ping me any time.
- [Man] Yeah.
- I want to interact
with the company often so
I'm always here.
- [Man] Yeah.
- Ad hoc on email like
hey why is this happening?
Or like this for 5, 10 minutes
or hey once a year can I get a
drink with you for 40 minutes,
the answer's yes to all.
- [Man] Yeah, I'd love
that. No, that's cool.
I will say it is nice.
I mean, I know it's
obviously a big thing at Vayner,
the stress of the culture
first coming but it's nice.
- I don't think
people understand how
important EQ and culture.
Culture is being thrown
around like entrepreneurship.
- [Man] Right,
well that's hot now.
- Correct. Correct. Correct.
So for me I take both very
seriously and I think that's why
we're getting the
results on both fronts.
- [Man] Yeah. Awesome.
I really appreciate it.
- My pleasure, buddy.
- [Man] Yeah. Thanks.
- Have a great day.
- [Man] Alright.
- I'll talk to you soon.
- [Man] Yeah.
(indistinct chatter)
- My son, Luke, watches it.
- So you're
gonna make a big cameo.
- I--
- You already made
a quick little one the
other day in our dinner.
- I've yet to watch it daily.
I watch about once a week.
- I'll take it. Thank you.
It's a real start.
- I say to myself, oh my
God is he signing more books?
("Fresh" by Evil Needle)
- There we go,
how are you, man?
That's exactly right.
And not only that, the reason
I replied because I would never
waste your time is I genuinely
believe that meditation's the
next enormous consumer space.
That in the same way that
Starbucks took over coffee and
the same way that Soul Cycle,
Equinox just kind of like the
physical health revolution back
to what you and I talked about
over the last 20, 30 years
that in 10 years every single
American is spending
real money on mental fitness.
("Fresh" by Evil Needle)
So, I think a lot
of the creative is
out of our hands until those
are out and we have some dollars
left over for the amplification
and the micro moments and
the cutting room floor,
that's where I think the Vayner
proper L.A. can
have a little say. Got it?
Have insights to the names of
the alternatives of the names
they gave us so
it's creatively on par.
We should leave next week with
a good idea creatively of what
we're doing with my main video
and who are the top 10 targets
to be the other
four faces of the brand.
Yeah, I don't want it out so
this is where it needs to die.
Obviously, some other
people know so Juliette,
whatever, make sure
nobody talks about it.
Okay.
Thanks guys.
Thank you.
("One More" by Rom)
Vayner Nation,
both my posts today,
like I can't
get off this kick.
Just ranting right now
talking straight to camera
who the fuck's permission
are you looking for?
Like it's either
your parent, your brother.
I can't believe how
many of you look to me.
Like everybody's
just looking for a nudge.
You need to figure
that out within yourself.
Like this is literally,
literally like jumping in a pool
and swimming for the first time.
Or like skydiving
for the first time.
Or kissing a boy
This is all the same shit.
Having sex for the first time.
Like proposing,
like having a child.
Living the life that you want
for yourself is the biggest
version of all those things
and it is my dream
that my content
creates that for you but I'm
scared that I'm not gonna
get to most of you.
I'm scared that I'm not
gonna get to most of you and I'm
scared that even the ones that
are giving me their attention
right now, I haven't been able
to penetrate yet because I have
to talk in generalities
'cause I don't know you.
I won't get the serendipity
of being in front of you.
But if this little commercial
break from the episode does
anything, please understand the
only person you need permission
from is yourself.
Great day. Going with my boys
now, AJ and Matt Higgins.
Heading on this helicopter.
I'm sure you'll
get a really cool shot.
Couple of, kind of a
secret business meeting.
Got to keep some
things secret, my friends.
Good day of hustle.
Feel really good.
You know, the electricity of the
action keeps me going forever.
I wish on you the love of the
game that I have my game and
I hope you guys
have a great night.
(helicopter whirring)
("Free As A Bird" by Rom)